not a big crowd um
okay well anyway um welcome to this
morning's uh
um oh god that's funny i forgot that i
have two roles here
this morning's uh workshop on um
on success you know batch methods and rl
and and all
we've got a great lineup today uh um
and i should get going so our first
speaker uh
on the program is on abuja but uh her
and her baby girl are both uh
quite not well i just got some
reassurance that
things seem to be stable but she's not
able to speak today so i'm speaking
i'm giving the lecture she would have
given which is
um some some really new results on what
we call zap stochastic approximation
and i'll talk about implications to key
learning um
so in terms of partners in crime
um we've got uh xiwang chen
who really really pushed all this
forward and did a lot of hard work
and then aditya who is the daddy of zap
and uh will be giving a talk after me
and fanlu who's
great help with simulations and all
sister a new graduate student
and of course anna bouchet she was the
speaker today
um and then crime um
is over here so basically the very
origins of some of the new results in
this paper
came out at a coffee shop near this uh
place near what near india
uh where anabolicity works and yeah
she's uh
you know she's a research scientist at
inuya in paris
in an awesome position there in computer
science at
ens on the other side of the river in
paris
and um you know i'd be introducing right
now and i'd say she
and i had a google research award and
she's done amazing work
in simulation methods and matching
models
and we've also done a lot of work i'm
excited about including working
reinforcement learning
so um but also many thanks to the
simon's institute
when aditya and i got to visit in 2018
it was absolutely and also anabushitz
was there it was absolutely incredible
for
all of our careers and of course thanks
to uh
our sponsors as well nsf and aro and
also note this
in next july there will be a textbook
based on
a lot of what i'm talking about today
and the boot camp in september
um okay so i'm going to give another
crash courses chest approximation
some of these slides are from the boot
camp um
that's where the mistake was aditya from
my boot camp
with a a typo corrected from the boot
camp
um a return to zap many of people seen
this before
but this story is a lot clearer now and
some really
some really wonderful new results on
stability and all that
and then get just end with some
simulation studies and that'll be it
and i'll ask the moderator to tell me
when five minutes are
up okay what a stochastic approximation
so
again i think many people have already
defined this
martin wayne or i mentioned this it's
about root finding
we have a function which is defined as
an expectation
and we would like to solve this using
some
simple scheme and the way it's done
is you first think about an ode and
first verify and this is what i would
call the od method is first
make sure that oda is well behaved so
what that means is
that the uh solution systeod
converge to a fixed point and
that means that this f bar of theta t
would converge to zero as desired
um this is this is the real goal you
know that's what that's what we're
trying to solve
um once you once you have verified that
then you can go through and you could do
an euler approximation
that'd be pretty silly because it would
be so complex so instead
you do this noisy euler approximation um
so you replace the expectation with
these random
measurements and sometimes w is fee
i just realized so w and f are the same
thing
later on it'll become a feed um and this
works
okay i mean convergence the stochastic
approximation is
it requires very little information
little um
assumptions at all um it's very very
much like the law of large numbers
so basically it's saying that oil
approximations are robust
you know um
and and that's it so um so
rates of convergence is hard convergence
is not so hard
all right so that's disgusting
approximation is
um yeah and again that's the message
that oral approximations are robust to
measurement error
that's all that's ever done in these
proofs of convergence
right refining or proves that early
schemes converge
all right um so
the the best reference is vivek barker's
monograph i mean of course there are
other great books
that vanessa tall is fantastic and and
kushner yen is encyclopedic
vivec's gonna have a new addition soon
it'll it'll be even better
um so again so here's the procedure
of design so again i've already said
step one
is to make sure that you get convergence
and again you're gonna have to modify
dynamics that's the entire point of
today's lecture
and also uh details as well is talking
about modifying dynamics
or changing the problem so you get
better uh a better ode
um and then there's an issue of gain
selection
so you know in q learning
in like the original papers and in all
the theorist stochastic approximation
at least historically it's often a
typical choice has been just
g over n and that is
justified because of the fact that you
get the optimal rate of convergence
the mean square error converges like 1
over n
under an assumption that we have this
hertz assumption for the linearization
matrix
at the equilibrium theta star so you go
and linearize that matrix
you make sure this matrix is hurwitz
which means you make sure g
the gain g is large enough and then you
get this one over n rate of convergence
under conditions you know um i mean now
you have the noise and so forth
um it requires some muscle
in general um and then you can actually
identify the constants because
this matrix here satisfies the lyapunov
equation
and so you actually know the constants
and this is central limit theorem and
all of that as well
all right so there's an issue of gain
selection now i'm not saying you have to
use
g over n in the end for the kinds of
algorithms i'm going to be talking about
we will have to use grn
i'll explain what i mean as we go um
all right so there are two sources of
error
that i really want everyone to
understand before you go home
one is the variance that has talked
about you know
um i'm going to when we talk about od
approximation
we have to make a change of time scales
so we solve this ode
but then we evaluate the time
at this new time scale where we sum the
step size alpha k
you know this alpha k is what appears
here
um and um so one is the fact that that's
you know sigma could be large
that's what i mean by number one there's
variance okay that's variance
and there's there's a missing thing
there um
it's yeah i mean sigma goes to zero but
it could be big
i mean you know
in the previous notation there's a one
over in there
um the other thing is is that
we've done a really good design so our
ode
is fantastic it converges very very
quickly
but we've got this awful scaling which
destroys everything
we're slowing down time through this uh
this
because of this uh this change of
variables
you know and that could destroy
everything
so this tau n
can be going very very slowly and
moreover in the non-linear that case of
nonlinear dynamics
we could really have trouble with gain
selection
and i'll give you some examples to
explain why okay but we
we see in rl applications that if you
take
even even with like a favorite choice
where you take
g over n plus one to the row where r is
less than one
well that's equal to one um if you're
far from equilibrium
you might have to crank up the game you
might need a really large g
but and then you're exploding the noise
by the way you know and so you've got
some problems there
but once you get closer then
we have a theory for what the optimal g
is
and it might be much much smaller and
have a completely different conclusion
and i'll give an example to try to make
this clear
in this talk all right and so here's an
example
so this this example is is mainly
about this the second point so it's it's
completely contrived example
just to you know just to show this
interesting phenomenon so
basically we're doing stochastic
gradient descent we have a
a loss function which is an expectation
and you see here that my fee turned into
a w of a w into a fee
and i chose it so it's quasi convex but
not convex
so it's gradient here you have f bar is
minus the gradient
it's a squiggly thing that was just
cooked up for fun all right
but it's causing convex so gradient
descent will work if we
if we could just do pure gradient
descent all right
now the th what i'm going to point out
here is that the asymptotic theory
of stochastic approximation we
concentrate
locally on the equilibrium here we have
theta star equals zero
and the fact that the slope is minus one
in a large scale
um you know we'd expect something very
very different
if we're looking at a very large initial
condition you know
so locally you converge like e to the
minus four t
because the slope here is minus four but
globally it's slower it's like either
minus t
you know look roughly speaking you know
um
to get a crisp bound is hard um
and um so it turns out that if you want
to chris bound
the only thing i know how to do is get a
this is basically this was known as a
sector non-linearity
and the lower sector is given right
there
and that is a slope of about minus a
third
okay minus 0.34 and
that turns out to give you a bound on
this rate
and once you have a bound on the rate of
convergence for the ode
then you get this very very sad story
right there where we get if we don't
make g big we're going to get this
crawling along convergence rate for just
the deterministic thing
so nothing sarcastic just our we've
transformed the ode so it
sucks let's blow everything away
okay so we we need g say bigger than two
maybe
to kill the stupid domestic behavior but
locally g star equals a fourth
is fantastic now this is a really boring
example because the difference between
two and a fourth isn't really that big i
could have fiddled around with this and
made it as big as i wanted i could have
made this
200 by making this more flat um you know
it's just a it's just
you know it was my first thought um
okay but the main thing is is this here
after
one million iterations if you use
this one over end step size with the
optimal gain
you won't get anywhere that's like three
seconds
you know take a look the
stochastic because it's the large
initial condition 100
they you can't see the volatility very
well there
the stochastic uh process and the
deterministic process
are falling to the really well but it
stops after less than three seconds
um even though n is a million you don't
get anywhere
um well if i crank up the gain by
putting this row here
so i've got remember there's a row
somewhere
if i make row less than one say point
nine then i get further i get all the
way up to
times about five seconds and if i make
it point eight
i get all the way to about eleven
seconds and there by then i'm really
i've been
i've been near the equilibrium for a
long time for the ode
and also the stochastic guy all right so
i i can hear a lot of you who are expert
suggested approximation saying
you're an idiot sean you all know that
you don't do this you do group and polio
averaging as martin wainwright talked
about
and yes solves the problem so
just go through and um oh yeah
don't forget it i there's a comment here
if you start off with theta zero equals
zero
you do get a clt kicking in like that if
you start off with theta equals 100 it
doesn't
but about rupert playing averaging it
solves the problem
okay for this problem what i do is i run
one of these algorithms with a with
a row less than one um average the last
two thirds say 80 of the run
and uh and what you get is perfect
perfect um optimal variance
and and and that said problem solved
so that's it crank up the gain average
the remaining fifty percent
done for this problem that's true
all right and the reason and the reason
is because
cranking up the game kills off the
non-linear dynamics
and then you reach steady state very
quickly you
you buy the high gain creates lots of
volatility while you average it out
and that's what poly code what averaging
is and you see here
that the central limit theorem is just
fantastic
and it converges very very rapidly all
right
all right does this always work no okay
so here's an example from q learning so
basically
um it turns out that martin wainwright
i guess it was around the same time i
think we did it first we showed that for
q learning
you need a a gain of one over one minus
beta to get
uh the right convergence rate uh martin
had some really
clever analysis and tighter bounds um
but we had this you know back in in a
few years ago
um and if you use that game
it works pretty well you know you get uh
volatility
and after a million samples this is for
the standard cat tattoo
learning there's still a bunch of
volatility but your bellman error
is reasonable now if you use the aditya
gain which you're going to learn about
in the next lecture it's just stuck
forever and doesn't do a thing
all right so rupert poliak to the rescue
will
crank up the gain in average well that's
what happens
so here's an experiment with oracle 0.85
which is high gain and that's you know
instead of one over n it's one over into
the 0.85
and a million samples and we see
it doesn't work it just fails
completely fails now you could fiddle
with this and eventually make it work
you could
you could probably fool around and crank
up the gain and do some averaging
it's not plug and play though you know
it's just not plug and play
now well for this particular problem
you're going to see that that
um a dt is going to have a solution
that's different than one
that i'm going to talk about but the
problem here is
when we're looking at higher dimensions
you've got these awful condition numbers
rupert like averaging might require a
nor you know
really big gain huge uh
increase in volatility of your estimates
and that takes a long time to average
things out
um and here you know we probably
probably could have used a larger gain
but then we would have needed larger
averaging all right so rupert pike is
not just like a so he can
abandon he can throw in anything and uh
and martin
actually had another example that made
that point as well
okay so what i want to talk about is
this return to zap q learning where you
can solve everything at once
and the main message here is that
there's new theory
uh that really is awesome um
so basically that uh just again
the challenges we've faced in this od
design for q learning and all of this
the whole rl community is faced
is stability we don't know how to design
the dynamics of the algorithm stable
and we don't even know if this solves a
relevant problem
you can say projected bellman era and
make yourself feel really happy
but double this and beam you know it
really it
if if you there are conditions would
mean something
like if the true q function is in your
function class but i don't expect that
to hold very often
so that's a big challenge um
and then also there's this condition
number issue and we have this one over
one minus beta
where beta is the discount factor
um and and that causes all sorts of
numerical problems
which have been talked about in almost
every lecture uh for the past few days
we've seen a one of our minus beta
in our behalf the lectures and in the in
the last
days um wouldn't it be nice if we could
linearize
make get a linear system you know
we want this to go to zero why not first
sort of linear system
f dot equals minus f why not do it
you know so that's it so basically this
is
now uh now we're calling
convis and friends in georgia tech i
call this the new raps and flow
uh vivek pointed out this was introduced
by smail in 1976.
vivek knows everything um and so you
know we we've got what we want
you know if we do this and that's what
zap q learning that's absolute
approximation is so
zap stochastic approximation just means
the
stochastic approximation translation of
the show to e
and you all know the chain rule so you
know that this turns into an od for
theta
because you can apply the the chain oil
on the left-hand side
all right and so basically the
trajectory is the solution
just moves in a straight line you know
towards zero
that's what this is saying
okay all right
so i'm just going to say a few words
about convergence and all that and how
to how to get an algorithm
so this is an algorithm basically you
introduce a matrix gain
because the newton raphson flow after
you perform the chain rule
has a matrix gain in it it has this
minus
a of theta t inverse where a is this
linearization matrix
that comes up in the variance analysis
so we have uh a matrix gain stochastic
approximation algorithm
and then we have online estimates of
this matrix
which we'd like to have all right and so
we have to have access
to the gradients um the derivatives of
this function f
well we'll have those in a neural
network setting as i'll talk about
okay now that the issue is
that we want to track a of theta
and so for that reason the only way
that's possible
is for this thing to be large you need
high gain
okay because we want to do this tracking
all right so basically again for this to
be true
we need high gain so gamma n over alpha
is going to go to infinity
and what we're going to do in this talk
is always
always always take alpha equals 1 over n
because if we don't do that
we're not going to get a reliable
approximation with the newton-raphson
flow
um i mean in the theory we're going to
do that
i mean in numerical experiments we will
hack around a bit
but for the theory for the theory to be
crisp and beautiful
we do that and then what we've done
everywhere is to take m and to be one
over to the row
or goes between a half and a one so it's
the standard
uh two time scale of a setting all right
um so the the stability is virtually
virtually
universal and
subject to assumptions of the noise and
so forth
you're getting the optimal variance
because in the end
you're using the matrix gain which is
the foundation for the optimal
convergence theory pioneered by rupert
and poliak
so um so you get everything you know you
get the two challenges they're all
killed in one shot
you get the optimal convergence rate the
optimal
with the optimal covariance and you
completely
kill the dynamics it becomes a linear
system
when you make a change of variables to
look at the f coordinates instead of the
theta coordinates
so it's just uh to me it's just a
beautiful a beautiful toy
yeah all right um
zap q learning so basically zap q
learning
we have a root finding problem in
standard q learning
um we have a function of theta which
you'll find in all of the
many many of the talks recently and all
the papers
um which is given here um
you know this lower bar whenever you see
a lower bar
it just means i'm taking a minimum
this is the standard uh fixed point
equation you're trying to i mean root
finding problem you're trying to solve
in q learning
and the most standard thing i can dq in
is just
take the gradient of the q function to
be this uh
this funky thing here all right so it's
a good fighting problem
and there's very virtually no theory for
stability or anything
um and again this is a hidden theory of
dqm
i mean some of you know you hadn't seen
of course
but a lot of you don't know that this is
really what dqn is trying to do
and also most extensions of watkins
jewelry algorithm
and what makes it difficult is we don't
we don't know anything
does it have a root we don't know uh is
there an inverse
we don't know and
um and then when we go to
zap
it's discontinuous because a of theta is
discontinuous
all right so um
but um the the theory of zap was
incredibly difficult because the lack of
continuity
so that's why this paper is so long on
trying to
show that even we don't even show that
the
od approximation holds we show that any
weak limit
of the scale process has enough
properties
so it mimics the important properties of
the new neups and flow
and it really took some mainly schwang
had to learn a lot about
uh generalized derivatives and stuff to
make it work
so that's that's what made it work but
this this stuff these first two things
i mean these are parts of the problems
with with q
learning even without sap i mean we
don't know about stability or anything
i mean theta dot equals minus theta i
mean
f bar theta nobody knows when that's
that's stable except for the tabular
case or or quantizing binning
things like that but it's really open
okay
but anyway so the paper resolves these
things um
so the video's sort of fun or a poster
where we talk about about these two
issues and we we use regularization
uh to deal with if a a is not invertible
we just look at
approximate inverse um but this is still
this is still open you know i mean we
just uh
we just took it for granted that has a
has a solution
uh it's amazing it always seems to to
have a solution
all right so let's just um let's wrap up
i'm i'm done i'm just going to show you
an example
we you know not me that's for sure i
wish i could do this
we ran this on a bunch of
standard examples like mountain car
you know acrobat card poll and just
took some neural networks and remember
we're trying to solve a root finding
problem
we're not minimizing anything there's no
optimization here it's a root finding
problem
and so we're not doing anything
we need a of theta equals partial
theta of f bar of theta
the estimates come from a neural network
you know um so we're not using neural
networks we're not doing gradient
descent
and what what's i mean it might not look
like much
but we're you know we're getting you
know great performance
but we're not messing with it just
always works we have theory to say it
always works
and when we run it we don't have to mess
around with meta parameters much it just
you know almost always works if we take
a neural network that's too small we'll
sometimes get crappy behavior
but there wasn't that much fiddling
around
there's a very very reliable approach um
and you know so so that's it that's all
i've got to say this is an example
so in conclusion
the start of the talk was about how
reinforcement learning is cursed by
dimension variance
and also the nonlinear algorithm
dynamics
second order methods can ensure
stability as well as give you great
variance bounds so use them when you can
in terms of future work a lot of us
would like to kill the projected bellman
area have some better
more approaches to cue learning
and also look at applications of
stochastic optimization
um we're looking at you know
acceleration techniques and
in recent work um and and
control variants could be an interesting
add-on to all of this um as it's been
used for electrocritic methods
okay but that's that's all i have to say
thank you and you'll see there's a
a bunch of references back here so
i think if there's a clarifying question
or something very quick
i should go to q a uh where is that
oh damn i can't see q a
um how funny
there are no questions though oh there
are questions okay
i mean i can't see anything uh okay cool
i think because i'm sharing my screen
it's blocked everything off so um
okay so i'm gonna do that so yeah
there'll be a break soon
and we'll have a great discussion then
and also i'll just introduce our next
speaker and i'll stop sharing